okay all
fine whatever um okay what up guys sorry
about that before i don't know what is
going on
with
um my camera my camera like kind of
glitched out hopefully that doesn't
become a pattern
as you guys know i always have tech
issues but at least you guys can be here
for the struggle right you can be see
the come up live
so so so so
ellie what are you doing what are you
i hear you causing a ruckus
okay
so oh no i don't know what am i doing
okay
guys i have some ex
stop it
okay
okay i have some exciting
announcements coming on the channel soon
and i want to tell you guys but i
shouldn't yet because
i got to get a couple things in place
but
you're going to be very excited
what is
all right i'm hoping i'm hoping
that this doesn't become a pattern
i'm wondering if it's like because my
pc's been running for a minute so
maybe all right well what do you guys
want me to react to let me know in the
chat while i make another t
okay
let me know in the chat
all right let me know in the chat
i put this on my instagram story
okay hold up i'm gonna make another chi
t put it in the chat what you want me to
react to i haven't done reactions in a
minute a minute guys
okay
okay
all right i got the water boiling
can you hear that
can you hear that
put a one in the chat if you can hear
that
rolo tomasi is saying the black pill is
death well the black pill is like
hopeless
if you're black pill that means you
think like nothing can happen
let me finish this to you
these are not you're getting a rare
reaction video from me i had some free
time
i thought i'd do it but this is rare i
promise you to god this is rare because
i
i don't have time like that anymore not
with these live shows which i think are
just giving you guys better content
but
you know
all right what should i react to
y'all
let me know in the chat
okay um
should i react to will and jada stuff
i kind of did that that better be decaf
yeah it is decaf it's like night tea
i think i did that already with my
sister
let's do red table talk
birthday actually that's that's a good
one to react to i have not
um
where is this
okay wait where can i find this let me
know in the chat where i can find this
will and jada
talk
birthday party
okay
i think this is the clip
fresh and fit if you guys want
i feel like their [ __ ] is like the same
like don't get me wrong
i know people want to like come at me
and say i'm like copying their thing
one
there's gonna be more differences which
are going to be very clear coming soon
with this new announcement that i can't
tell you guys yet um but
on top of that
[Music]
um
i'm a girl and it's different coming
from one woman's point of view and three
like their [ __ ] has just been the same
for over a year
like i don't know i just get bored of it
but
um
rolo holds the title for longest the day
after her 37th birthday
i hired a teen to orchestrate her 40th
birthday i hired a documentary team why
does the mom look disgusting traced
mommy's family roots her 40s sound okay
let me know in the chat birthday was
going to be my thing this is going to be
a splash there's going to be a splash
mary j blige mary j blige performed i
debuted the film all of that it was
going to be the thing that lifted her
out of this midlife crisis and she it
was going to be my
deepest most beautiful proclamation of
love and she's told me that the party
was the most ridiculous display of my
ego
crushed
right
and
to this day i know i was crushed because
it was true oh my god this poor man
will i'm single
i promise you could throw me a birthday
party everybody i promise
i promise i'll be okay
ah
okay um let me look at the chat
see what people say um
oh my god that's like wild to me
react to pack and jada dancing to will
smith music okay
i know it was true they brainwashed the
man
oh gosh okay my tea is ready hold on you
guys gonna give me a second
in one second
okay we're gonna let it sit for a minute
and i'm gonna go back to it okay
you've been waiting for me to say you're
sick
will smith
who keeps changing the names in the chat
i've been waiting for you to say you're
single i'd love to date you pearly as
soon as i drop jada
i'm waiting okay
i mean i mean i have like so many
options like it's crazy like so many
okay
anyways um
let's see
play
all right tupac and jada dancing to will
smith's song
okay
react to this
[Music]
this this is brilliant
oh my gosh she was fine back in the day
like damn
we're gonna get this in one second now
you went to school with tupac right
yeah yeah
and you guys sort of dream together
am i right
yes well we have
as a treat
the first performance
of the duo of tupac and jada
singing
singing
very ironically
parents just don't understand check this
out
[Applause]
shower
i don't understand will you could have
had so many [ __ ]
you picked the one [ __ ] that was in
love with tupac you could have had so
many [ __ ]
i swear to god
including
[Music]
but my mom said no no way um
that's the funniest that is the funniest
thing i've ever seen mommy went all out
oh my god
okay what else what else should i do um
dude what's apex mindset
um
oh no alpha mindset
let's see
oh wait i think i've seen this guy on
twitter
oh my god i totally have seen this guy
before
there is one video i should show you
guys
and i don't
know where it is
um
he had a really good video that i
thought was like amazing
and i can't figure it out
um okay
i think something like that
yeah this one
if it's just straight hey bro improve
your okay yeah this is the one i was
expressing bro just like lift weights
and look smack wait i'm sorry guys we're
gonna start it over i'm getting my t
i'll be back hold on
um
[Music]
okay
guys
also if you want to support the channel
i know i hate to do it i hate to do it
send super chats i'm busting my ass
i am busting my ass
for this channel i'm just being honest
here we have some really cool
improvements thanks to your donations
that are coming
unfortunately my soundboard for the next
four mics is delayed by three weeks
but
but
but
i have some other updates coming and i'm
really excited about
so i need you guys to support the stream
if you can
like it doesn't have to be a lot it
could just be five bucks
but i'm busting my butt
trying to get this off the ground
and you're gonna be excited with some
stuff that's coming i promise
okay
now i'm gonna do this if it's just
straight hey bro improve your smv bro
just like lift weights and looks max and
make money and you'll be fine if that
was the only thing that mattered how
come these girls are putting up barriers
i mean i must be something wrong with me
i must be genetically unattractive
somehow this is the the talk that they
tell themselves which sabotages them and
why i want to remove that stuff for you
guys here today
i'm straight busted right now you're
ah you're too much
[Music]
this was a thing that a client had a
question on i've had clients have
multiple questions on they can't figure
it out because their game is getting
better they're getting more success with
women but they notice like these women
putting up
barriers
between
you know moving things along in a pickup
sense
but
other guys who are
way douchier
seem to be able to get in on that same
girl or same type of crowd right like
her ex-boyfriend's just douchebag
or whatever or guy the glass guy she
slept with or the guy okay pause for a
second
thank you for the super chat i
appreciate you we got you i might do a
reaction to one of your videos please do
guys all you doing reactions to my stuff
gets the word out there about this
channel i'm trying to get this off the
ground and i need you
i need every single one of you
to share the videos like the videos
donate if you can
like none of this goes i appreciate two
dollars pearly's ass just messed with
messing with you pearly
okay
you know
there's other super chats you could have
sent but i i'll take it thank you thank
you okay i'm gonna keep
reacting type of guy she normally sleeps
with is lower smv
than you hitting on her and she's
putting barriers up and a lot of guys
are like dude what is going on and the
problem with that is it messes with your
self-confidence right and i don't want
it to mess with your self-confidence i
have a lot of guys who are client
clients that come to me who are
high-value guys
they are killing it you know they're
killing it at life
and they seem to think
that they're they don't really
understand their value to a woman like
they don't understand how marketable
they actually are the only thing missing
is game the rest of it is there like
these guys are well over six figure
earners
look they look good in good shape they
got a lot of things going for them and
then
you know they're getting a lot of misses
now of course they went after
sixes that would be fine they would be
getting sixes all day but
a lot of cases some of these cases i can
think of they're going for younger girls
all right meaning that they're let's say
34 years old or 33 or 36
sometimes even in their 40s and they're
talking to 21 year old girl which by the
way
i get guys that are in in those age
categories in fact they just had
somebody two people in fact send me a
message hey i'm i'm uh regularly seeing
this 21 year old and we're having a
blast and then you know owe it all to
you bro you know so
women who are 21 22 they're attracted to
guys in their 40s and their 30s so don't
let that fool you don't let the female
shaming attack okay i will say i did not
get attracted to old guys until i was
like 23 24.
but
i more girls do it thank you for the
five dollar super chat you got
there's 20 people in here three of you
have donated like you guys got me okay
did you see the debate with the panel of
men and some trans women talking about
trans athletes no but remind me after
this video and i'll react to it
critics of the world tell you otherwise
um but
they run into these barriers i'm trying
to figure this out like if it's just
stretch straight hypergamy and if it's
just straight hey bro improve your smv
bro just like lift weights and looks max
and make money and you'll be fine if
that was the only thing that mattered
how come these girls are putting up
barriers i mean i must be something
wrong with me
i must be genetically unattractive
somehow this is the the talk that they
tell themselves which sabotages them
well i want to remove that stuff for you
guys here today
so i figured this out a while ago
um because i would have girls that would
sleep with me very quickly when i was
single and uh out there more for that
right and i've i have a girl that was
still my ltr suits me very quickly right
like we still have those experiences but
um
but i mean if i'm you know when i'm
single of course i'm actually hitting on
girls and putting myself out there and
um
yeah like it was weird because you would
have some girls asleep with you like
this and other girls who would put up
barriers
and what was he talking about
like why do girls sleep with the bombs
basically but not like the guys that are
better looking and all have more smv
okay
i'm gonna wait for him to talk because
i've watched this video before and i
actually think he's a great take on it
eat godly would i date randy orton i
don't know who that is is that this guy
let me know in the chat and i will tell
you
interesting
was this here's kind of what i noticed
is that
when i got my physique
dialed in to a point and no i'm not
saying just get your physique dialed in
it's the only thing but this is just
what caused light bulb to go on okay
when i got my physique dialed into a a
point and i'm not at that point right
now i'm about 20 pounds over that point
right which at a
245 pound guy though 20 pounds is
nothing but it's a difference between
being like
sick shredded where i walk around a
beach like this and everyone's like whoa
that guy is jacked and shredded like
what like everyone looks at you versus
you know people look at you they see it
you're a big dude but you look more
normal all right and i know girls don't
necessarily go for shredded guys they
don't necessarily want the big guys
that's not a whole nother discussion
okay
but
when i got myself really shrek i think
you want shredded if you're shredded but
like i'd be self-conscious you know what
i mean
where i turned heads there's more now a
novelty i noticed girls would actively
seek me out sleep with me right away
girls who
would put less barriers up you know
and what had occurred to me
was that the girls that were putting up
barriers
i'm not talking about every single girl
of course there's some girls just not
attracted that aren't attracted to me
they're not gonna be attracted to you
and that's okay but the vast majority of
them it's like i'd get them on dates i
get them out or i get engagement on a
pickup
but then they'd have these barriers oh
shoot it's like
my friend's here
i was live streaming
um